el festival de cine de cannes vive sus
últimas horas y el jurado presidido por
band son landon vio las últimas dos
películas de la competencia
la estadounidense kelly reichardt está
en cannes con su último largometraje
show y no el retrato de una artista
atormentada yo vi no ves la historia de
lis y una escultura que trata de
terminar las últimas fiestas para una
exposición pero diversos obstáculos le
impiden concentrarse en su arte el
principal atributo de esta cinta es la
actuación de michelle williams en el
papel de esta artista taciturna
de su lado la francesa lyon hoxe hai
presentó en la competencia a petit frac
la historia de una madre marfileña y de
sus dos hijos
esta crónica comienza cuando rosa llega
a los suburbios de parís desde costa de
márfil la cinta resume 15 años en la
vida de estos tres personajes en la
francia de los años 80
l
el jurado del festival de cannes
completó así su maratón de 21 películas
y será el sábado por la noche que se
conozca en los premios sobre todo la
palma de oro de esta edición